a little Victoria since that
welcome thank you come it is intimate
beautiful sets and it's an honor really
uh and the beam with Frederickson onna
whoa you know she's my boss she's sweet
I would cook this is what is we could do
this in Norwegian if you will yeah uh
but let's do it in English okay let's do
it and what I read about beauty of the
day was that you talk about Victoria
sills that that won't we just saw hair
as as a character well I guess we all
play a role in our career I mean
especially in the business that I've
been in or in entertainment world
I mean specially as a blonde and you
know obviously I'd like to play the role
but it's also nice to kind of know the
distance like to step out of it and just
be yourself you know
are you aware when you step into it I am
aware but I also like it so much because
I made a business out of it now you're
the real Victoria I am do you feel you
have this in an ounce of a character
from time to time that people expect you
to be a certain way
um I think people expect me to be a
certain way yeah I don't play into it
but I do think that people have
perceptions you make movies I see you
everywhere now you know and they think
oh god is going laughs you're just so
funny you're so happy all the time and
you know I always say why I am happy but
make me laugh because I don't you know
the true Victoria started out I wanted
to be a skier a downhill skier you know
I just talent yeah well I kind of got
pushed into the very early age my father
pushed me my sister to the ski team at
five years old so I think that's when I
kind of got this sense of competent that
I love the competitions is an early age
and you look so I've been pushing my the
very best way we haven't in Sweden
Piniella Bieber and I were competing
together so she was quite something she
did beat me though I was faster I was
better in super-g in giant slalom but
she beat mint slalom so I
Kimberly with that today so he chose
another profession exactly I had a
really bad accident in a downhill race
where I actually broke my shoulder and I
was around 15 16 years old and my mom
was like this is enough you're not doing
this anymore my father was so upset so
my mom sent a photo into Miss Sweden
pageant so that's kind of how kind of
changed it all yeah but but tell me
anything that's hard broke something but
something else open up there we go yeah
oh you you ended up spending and this is
really is a far travel because you you
became Playmate of the Year
well there was kind of a after miss
Sweden Miss World little modeling in
Paris and then whoops ended up in LA yep
um six and I don't regret it
honestly like I was like Playboy but
honestly it kind of got me to America
and the American dream that we all dream
about in age of 18 so it did kind of
open the doors a lot of doors yeah and
it spent a lot of time not in fact a lot
of time in the Playboy Mansion you
actually lived there didn't you
well when you go there to do a test
shoot whatever that's how I had to go
the first time you do get to spend time
there and live at the mansion and I was
very scared going there because I was
really really nervous
so thank her when I arrived miss
Kimberly Hefner was greeting me with her
arms open so I thought it was only gonna
be half and and you know bunch of guys
so I was just relieved that she was the
bubbly is the Hefner the xxxxX way out
one and uh but it was fine it was you
know it wasn't how much it there oh how
is that things I mean it's my first time
I live no it was a nice dream exam a B
but it's a lost world to live in so um
it is it was kind of a locked up
community we couldn't bring anybody up
there without approval and this is the
time before you had cell phones or
anything some I didn't really tell my
mom where I was staying
so it was kind of odd when
find out where I was and she called on
the butter picked at the bomb hello
paper mansion and she couldn't okay
wrong number she kept calling me : I
found it by the way is my daughter there
I was like oh well it's not really what
you think you know I was a bit
embarrassed I was kind of a little bit
of a rebel you know that never even told
my mom it's after so I guess they all go
through that um well you ever there did
you ever I know a lot of men who did go
uh-huh
I never went to the Playboy Mansion no
no but it was I get out quite a hangout
for the gala and pretty girls and
smooth-skinned and all that stuff that
men like to look at and I don't want
them
you knew Donald Trump at the time
actually I was roommate with his wife
Melania we lived together in Paris we
both started modeling together it
struggling model he's not sure the
future wife first lady maybe and and
then yeah so how well did you know him I
knew Donald because um when I had this
whole Playboy Playmate of the Year I
also got a guest cheese contract and I
was all around traveling and I don't
know how he found out he started sending
me flowers he found out where I was and
sending me things and kind of aura we're
kind of after me a little bit but it
wasn't my favorite what they've been
there so how did you make him understand
that uh what kind of not responding to
anything on the messages and just kind
of keep your cool but I guess you know
he must have liked that
I mean aha man is when you say no they
say go so much he must wish he had your
hair too oh yeah yeah
do you think that that we have misread
him in Europe he's kind of I mean the
cult reversal kinda your noxious mean
yeah probably a bit bad perspective
perhaps honestly when I did meet him
once after all the processes I did
accept at a lunch but that was it that
was the end of it but it was all about
I'm the best I'm the greatest I'm the
best I'm the greatest I'm the best me me
me me me and you're just like being from
Sweden that's not happening it's no
would you wish him all the best luck so
you wish she would be present he's gonna
need it you know I wish it for his wife
Melania to be first lady where love is
something else I was a roommate with the
first late of United States of America
yeah and yeah you're also a day trader
as its called
you trade with stocks currency effects
yeah I do this for myself I don't give
any advice to nobody but this has become
like kind of an addiction it kind of
started after the bank crash in 2008
we're kind of on almost all my money
that I worked hard for was invested and
kind of got wiped out I'm sure a lot of
people were in that situation so then
after that I took it all in my own hands
and I said I'm not gonna trust nobody
this is me every penny is me who
controls I want to know where the
investments are I want to take care of
it everything myself so I started slowly
to follow what's happening and it became
kind of addiction I started doing forex
trade started with shortening the Euro
against a dollar when I was about 151
150 160 I've been following this from
from years and that's how I've been
gaining a lot actually
so I hadn't I've been also doing other
currency dollar against Swedish kronor
$1 NOK and just kind of felt wrong with
a pan oh I've nothing against a pound
but you know you stick to the things
that kind of you know steena Norway
you're a dollar yeah this is really
basic you got it the wrong way around
and then
not only lose all the money you've
already lost but yeah some you haven't
even gone but you know what you do like
if I do like a forward contract so it's
kind of like a loan so you don't really
play with all the money do you have in
your account it's like a forward
position so if you forward like 1
million it doesn't mean you have to have
them what a month or a year yeah one
month you can extend like yeah exactly I
do like normally month-to-month you know
but you say currency because currency
isn't it's it's a bit risky
what would you would you consider a
property instead what do you like I do
own proper I think property is obviously
the best thing to own do you buy at the
right time but um this is it's not the
same adrenaline rush this is something
that I wake up in the morning I check
what's happening the Asian market I
found a European mark and the u.s.
closed so and it's just kind of
something that I do everyday basis and
I'm doing also it's a it's a hell of a
gamble isn't it it's a gamble have you
been again you just look like money on
the gamble way way way back fifty years
ago I invested in a company called aqua
blast on the advice of the Bank of
Boston and lost every penny oh you're a
real gambler shares when you've heard
like that and and sat down and wrote the
first book very stupidly thinking this
will make money anybody writes a book
thinking they're make money is a
complete nut case I would never gamble
again it's very interesting you raise it
because I've been listening to you very
badly terrifying to gamble two
currencies against each other I wouldn't
have a clue
well euro against dollar is kind of the
safest you can go because you know that
the euro and the dollar is not gonna
both like I mean it's kind of a the
currents that kind of follow each other
to close so book all the currency wars
have you read I haven't read it
you guys read it that's a good yeah very
strong but with all that a ballot yeah
well it's kind of based on the dollar
mean it's based on the government
control basically the the I did have a
big lost on currency but I'm a UH I mean
I had a quite a loss because the Swiss
National Bank broke the floor the had a
floor you're a Swiss at 120 where they
have promised whenever break we're gonna
keep on 20 against the dollar
not euro against Swiss they kept again
or guaranteed at 120 and they kept
saying we're guaranteeing this floor and
what they did is shocked everybody oh
yeah your saw and I don't know how many
people and how many pawns did well
because at the in theory you saw that
anymore you should believe a nation
examination yes they actually came no
saying as a reliever there was an entry
saying we're so you cannot hundred
percent always trust the government
either so I did get hurt in that
position but working it back with the
euro dollar in and out in would you
invest is the duties kind of investment
or are you more you know quite Servet if
actually in fact I danced in Vegas when
I was younger and I I never gambled are
you in property or where we're going
where do you put your money in property
property so you have a lot of lots of
homes yeah I'm homes and property I
think it's the most stable and if you
can sit in it for a long time and just
make sure that you're not buying and
selling I look back what then you know
you look crew you know alaya nice
annuity for yourself and what would you
recommend and you just started to make a
lot of money would you take her advice
or well advice from these people of
course they say it's not advising myself
it's an interest for Victoria and you
know you you you get a you get a kick
out of it ya know you say like when
you're writing is the dread around so
you know you you make a call right it's
your money you made your money exactly
of course and when you lose you or you
lose it so me Jesus do you gamble on
horses or do you we're not allowed we
don't win dollars gamble no way we're
not allowed to gamble because we they
call inside information
oh yeah I think we know something I know
I can I know something about a horse
that died on the race course that's at
the bookies doesn't know you know um so
we're not allowed full stop that's it
and but I'm with you up for for property
and investing it that's something I can
wrap my arms around yeah we tried to win
it back
it's fantastic to have yours thank you
so much thank you please welcome Evelyn
Glennie
you